Hello, and thank you again for joining us
for this NCBI minute.
Today we will explore the save search feature
which can provide automatic email updates
on a daily weekly or monthly basis, and conclude
with creating a customized named collection
from our search results that can be made public
to share with others.
Let's get started with saving and managing
a search.
The easiest way to begin is at the PubMed
home page located at www.pubmed.gov.
If you are not already signed into NCBI, don't
worry you will be prompted later.
For my example, I am automating my PubMed
search for Adolescent COPD.
Step 1 is to enter my query or search terms.
If you are interested in a tutorial on how
to construct a query,
information will be provided at the end of
this presentation.
But in general, the PubMed process is from
left to right and
dates and ranges are not recommended for saved
searches.
Step 2 Click the Search button.
Next, click 'create alert', which is located
beneath the search bar.
A popup window will appear.
Again, if you are not logged into your NCBI
account, you will be prompted to sign in.
Now it's time to save the search name.
The default is the search.
A couple of things to remember.
The saved search name may be up to 100 characters
long and this will become the subject line
of your email.
Queries can be quite cumbersome, so I updated
it.
Next, is the original search query from PubMed.
You are also able to modify your terms from
here.
If you edit your search terms, always remember
to click Test search terms.
This will provide the number of items based
on the edited search.
Although I did not modify the search, it shows
that there are 3 thousand 1 hundred and 31
results found at the time of this screenshot.
Do you want your new search results sent automatically
to your email?
I do, so Yes, please is selected.
We will discuss a little later what happens
if you say No, thanks.
Next, visually confirm your email address,remembering
that
Automatic e-mail updates can only be sent
to e-mail address
that have been confirmed.
If an e-mail bounces back three times, the
email address will be changed to unconfirmed.
Also, you may consider adding nih.gov to your
email safe list.
If you do not know how to do this, please
contact your email
provider's customer support for assistance.
To verify that your email address is confirmed,
click on your username
or Change.
As you can see, the email address has been
confirmed.
Otherwise, a link would appear allowing you
to resend the confirmation email.
Now, let's return to saved searches and
schedule the frequency of the email.
For monthly, choices include:
-The first Sunday through Saturday.
-The first day of the month
- or The first WEEKDAY of the month.
- Weekly
- And finally, daily.
Next, select the format.
The choices are Summary, Abstract and Medline.
Let's take a look at the actual email.
The examples shown are from Outlook 2016.
All emails consist of the name of the saved
search and in this one I re-edited the name.
Sender's message is optional text that can
be included in each email.
Next, is the date sent, my PubMed search terms,
the ability to view the complete results in
PubMed, the ability to edit the search, and
of course unsubscribe.
And finally, the PubMed emailed results in
Summary format.
Here is an example of how the same result
as it appears in the Abstract format.
And in the Medline format.
Back to our customized Saved Search.
Select the maximum number of items to appear
in the email.
In order to verify that the alert is running
properly, use send even when there aren't
any new search results.
In the event an update is not sent out as
scheduled or incomplete, the next scheduled
update will include the missing items.
Here, you may include any optional text that
you wish to be added to your email.
And click save.
You will be immediately taken back to the
PubMed search page and will see the confirmation
here.
You are also able to edit your search settings
at any time if needed.
Earlier, I pointed out that you could click
'No, thanks' to an email search result.
Let's take a quick look at My NCBI where the
saved search is stored.
Since we are logged into NCBI, click the My
NCBI link located next to your username.
As you can see, in the saved searches portlet,
there are two PubMed Searches.
The one we just created Adolescent COPD and
another Lung Cancer.
For Lung Cancer, I selected 'no, thanks'.
I do not want email updates.
The 'What's New' column shows that there are
220 citations currently available since I
last looked at my results 3 days ago.
'What's new' is available for all searches.
For example, if Adolescent COPD delivers on
a weekly basis,
I can still log into NCBI to see if there
are added citations since my last email run
and view the citations by clicking on the
numbered link.
The 'Saved Search' portlet has the ability
to manage saved searches.
From here, you can quickly look at your scheduled
email delivery and edit your saved search
by clicking either on the gear or schedule
link.
If you check the box next to the search name,
you are able to Delete the selected item or
items and also see what's new.
Now, let's talk about building a collection
by going back to the My NCBI homepage.
My NCBI comes with default collections of
My Bibliography, Other Citations and Favorites.
Today, we will be creating a customizable
titled collection to share with others.
For your convenience, we have great tutorials
on the default collections
that will be included at the end of this presentation.
Although we are starting from saved searches,
you may also conduct a search directly in
PubMed.
Remember, clicking on Lung Cancer beneath
the PubMed Searches column
will re-run the search and display the results
in PubMed.
Likewise, if I click the link under 'What's
New', I will only have access to the 220
new citations based on my search.
From here we are taken to PubMed, which contains
my saved search results.
Select a few of the citations for the collection
and click 'Send to'.
If all of the citations should be included
, simply click 'send to' and up to 1,000 citations
will be added to the collection.
Select the destination of 'Collections',
verify the number of items selected, and click
'Add to collections'.
The pop out window will automatically show
'Append to an existing collection'.
This is where the pre-defined collection 'favorites'
and personally titled
collections will reside.
Today we are creating a new collection.
So we will enter the name of the collection
and click save.
We are returned to the PubMed page where we
receive a confirmation of the saved items
and the opportunity to edit the collection
lung cancer in My NCBI.
You are also able to return to the My NCBI
homepage by clicking on
the My NCBI link located next to your username.
Lung cancer now appears in the collection.
Today we will click 'edit' to make the collection
public and to generate a URL to share.
In the gold box, click the link 'make it public'.
Confirmation of the update will appear above
the gold box, along with the generated URL
for this collection.
URL retrieval is located in edit settings,
found in the gold tool bar,
By clicking on the gear next to the collection
from the My NCBI homepage
or the link Private/Public also located on
the My NCBI homepage.
From the edit page
- You can modify the name of the collection
- Make the collection private or public
- Retrieve the URL for the public collection
- and gather the HTML code.
If the collection was public and changed back
to private, the URL and HTML will no longer
work and the URL may change once made public
again.
You may also wish to save this collection.
In display setting, located in the blue tool
bar, click the down arrow to sort the collection
by date, author, or title.
Additionally, items may be deleted by selecting
'all' or checking the box next to the citations,
clicking delete, and 'OK' to confirm.
Selected citations may be personally viewed
in the PubMed browser by clicking 'view'.
Finally, manage all collections from here
or from the My NCBI homepage by click Manage
collections.
Merge and delete are only available for custom
Meaning that Favorites, My Bibliography and
Other Citations cannot be merged or deleted.
Also you are able to check the date last modified
by hovering over the text.
This concludes the brief tutorial on how to
create an automated search, create a collection
and activate a public URL.
If there are any remaining questions, please
feel free to ask them at this time.
And once again thank you for joining us.
[Peter Cooper speaking] Okay thank you Sherri,
there was one question in the Chat Box, I
did not answer, is it not possible to export
a collection to Endnote?
[Sherri Bailey] You cannot do this in your
personalized, customized collection, however
you can do this either in My Bibliography,
or Other citations.
There is a link after the questions, which
will give you a step-by-step method on how
to export from those collections, meaning
My Bibliography, or Other citations.
[Peter Cooper] Another question, is there
a way to automatically save Collections as
PDF's?
[Sherri Bailey] Not at this time.
That is a great suggestion we will pass on.
[Peter Cooper] Okay.
Thank you I don't see any other questions
in the question pod.
Sherri is showing the last slide here, additional
documents you may find helpful.
There is a two minute PubMed Search Tutorial
available.
And there is a YouTube video on using My Bibliography
and Other Citations.
Just to remind you to keep up on NCBI see
the Insights blog, at ncbiinsights.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
And we do have a YouTube channel; ncbinlm
is the channel name.
For any questions about NCBI resources, please
write to info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
If you have specific questions about the webinars,
write to webinars, that's webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
Thanks everyone for coming.